it's my name is James Milius I'm a
senior here at Hillsdale originally from
Beaverton Oregon
I'm studying philosophy in sociology and
I'm here to introduce our speaker for
tonight dr. Frank dikötter is chairman
and professor of humanities at the
university of hong kong and senior
fellow at the Hoover Institution
previously he taught at the School of
Oriental and African Studies University
of London from which he earned his PhD
he has written numerous books including
the discourse of race in modern China
China before Mao the age of openness and
crime punishment and the prison in
modern China dr. Takata is the author of
people's trilogy a work that documents
the impact of communism on the lives of
ordinary people in China the first
volume Mao's Great Famine won the 2011
Samuel Johnson prize for nonfiction the
second the tragedy of liberation was
shortlisted for the Orwell Prize in 2014
the final installment the Cultural
Revolution was shortlisted for the Penn
hessel Tilton Prize in 2017 would you
please join me in welcoming dr. Frank
Takata
[Applause]
good evening thank you for coming I'm
delighted to be here a little jet-lagged
I arrived from London yesterday I got up
at 5 o'clock in the morning I couldn't
wait any longer so at 7 o'clock I went
outside and walked around the campus so
here's a fact there's nobody to be seen
in Hillsdale on a Sunday morning at 7
o'clock not a soul
I did see a few chaps one of them is
called George and a very distinguished
lady called Maggie
now if thirty years ago somebody would
have asked Margaret Thatcher what is the
organization Department in the People's
Republic of China or for that matter the
organization Bureau or Oracle as the
Russians used to say I think she would
have frowned I think she would have said
young man back you go to communism 101
about a month ago at the Hoover
Institution I was asked to speak to
twenty senior congressional fellows all
very small or quite distinguished I
asked them do you know what the
organization Department is in the
People's Republic of China not not a
single one of them knew what that was
so understanding China there's this
theme of this conference if you do not
know what an organization department is
you do not understand China
it's as simple as that if you do know
you don't have to say but there's good
news at the end of my talk you will know
what it is and I hope you will have a
better idea of the entity that we are
dealing with my brief is to talk about
the Chinese Revolution which thousand
1949 I will focus mainly on the 30 years
under Mao but I will also spend about
eight nine minutes talking about China
over the last 40 years bringing it up to
date now like the organization
Department
or the org bureau everything invariably
starts in the Soviet Union in this case
it starts with Stalin no Stalin no Mel
it's as simple as that
on the 6th of August 1945 Hiroshima in
Japan is a raised in a blinding flash of
light two days later
Stalin sends a million man across the
border from Siberia into Manchuria the
industrial powerhouse of China to the
north of Beijing they are on their way
to Korea where they wait for the
American allies along the 38th parallel
Japan surrenders the Russians don't
leave they hand over North Korea to Kim
il-sung and the countryside in Manchuria
- the Chinese Communist leader mounts at
home they help him transform his ragtag
army of guerrilla fighters into a
formidable fighting machine the Russians
established 16 military institutions
including Air Force artillery and
engineering schools some Chinese
officers go all the way to Moscow for
advanced training logistical aid arrives
by rail and by sea in North Korea alone
some 2,000 maggin loads are allocated to
the task the Americans on the other hand
impose an arms embargo on the wartime
ally Chiang kai-shek and the
Nationalists Chiang kai-shek loses
battle
that battle in a war of attrition in
Manchuria by 1948 the Communists feel
strong enough to start surrounding
cities and blockading them in the case
of chunks would lean be all one of Mao's
generals commands the city to be
transformed into a city of death his
troops establish a perimeter around
Chang Shan trenches four meters deep and
do not allow anyone to leave for five
months 160,000 ordinary people are
starved to death
jeong jeong long a lieutenant with the
chinese communist army noted later on
that Hiroshima and Chun Kuen were the
same Hiroshima took 9 seconds
Shankaran took five months the
casualties were roughly design other
cities surrender unwilling to undergo
the same fate by the end of 1949 Chiang
kai-shek and the Nationalists flee to
Taiwan the red flag goes up over the
Forbidden City in Beijing it is called
liberation a term that brings to mind
jubilant crowds who welcomed the
liberators but liberation is the result
of a long and brutal war of conquest
power Mao used to say power comes from
the barrel of a gun but now
you very well that the People's
Liberation Army could only keep power
for so long what was required was a
revolution the overthrow of the old
order and it came in the guise of a
campaign for land reform it had very
little to do with the land had an
everything to do with power communists
work teams fanned out into villages and
polarized closely knit communities into
a majority obliged to denounce a
minority of victims frequently that
democratically elected village leaders
some villagers did this with relish but
a great many had no choice because those
who refused would be denounced in turn
the victims who had announced as
landlords tyrants evil gentry humiliated
beaten sometimes killed their assets
distributed to the crowd so in a fact
ordinary people entered a pact sealed in
blood with the party all of them had
blood on their hands all of them had
participated in the persecution of a
small number of victims they did not
want chiang kai-shek and the Nationalist
Party to reach her this is land reform a
year later in October 1950 Chairman Mao
decided that it was time to eliminate
all the enemies standing in the path of
the revolution
spies bandits counter-revolutionaries he
issued a killing quota of one per
thousand go out kill one without me in
many parts of China local Carter's some
pronounces as cadres local Carter's or
Communist Party members try to vie with
each other and show their revolutionary
determination so that this quota doubled
or traveled in the south some of these
party activists used the campaign of
terror to settle accounts with the local
population which resisted the arrival of
the Communists entire villages were
raised in some cases school children as
young as six were accused of spying for
the nationalists sometimes a few
prisoners were simply taken out and
short for a local official to meet his
killing quota of one per thousand people
were supposed to be shot in public and
rallies taking place in stadiums which
all had to witness but in many cases
they were taken deep into forests along
rivers near ravines alone or in batches
about 1.5 to 2 million people were
eliminated coming on top of the two
million people denounced as landlords
during so-called land reform so by now
we're counting in the 4 to 5 million
victims many more were stigmatized for
life and disappeared into a sprawling
prison system across the country
to paraphrase Simon Schama the historian
of the French Revolution violence was
the revolution but of course violence
had trusted companions namely fear and
intimidation people across the realm
were asked to transfer them transform
themselves into what the party called
new people there to go back to school in
factories and offices and learn the
right answers learn the right ideas
learn how to shout the right slogans
there to confess account for the past
activities demonstrate the loyalty to
the party
possibly denounce colleagues neighbors
family members well of course there's
more than just violence and intimidation
the history of revolution in China is
also a history of promises made and
promises broken mouths like Lenin and
the Bolsheviks promised every
disaffected group what they wanted most
more land for the villages freedom of
speech for intellectuals independence
for minorities protection of private
property for entrepreneurs better
working conditions for the workers one
by one these promises were destroyed as
Mao imposed a harsh Stalinist system on
the country one by one the enemies were
eliminated it started first with the
counter revolutionaries at the height of
this campaign of terror that I just
described but then the campaign moved on
to target
former government servants who had been
promised lenient treatment by the
communists in 1949 but were eliminated
or targeted in 1952 and after that the
business community was brought to heel
every organization outside of the
organization of the Communist Party of
China was eliminated religious
communities philanthropic associations
powerful chambers of commerce labor
unions all of them eliminated and
replaced by the party for 1956 all
enterprises were nationalized and became
functions of the state if you had been
running a corner shop in Shanghai and
you would be pleading with the party to
be allowed to continue to work as a
state employee the land was taken back
from all the villagers who lost their
freedom of movement by 1956 they had to
sell the grain they produced to the
state at state-mandated
prices but something happened in 1956
that upset the Chairman is morale
spanning had died three years earlier in
February 1956 his successor Nikita
Khrushchev in a secret speech that very
much shook the socialist camp to his
core denounced Stalin his reign and
terror and called a personality now
viewed it as a personal attack he after
all was China's Stalin his answer was to
come up with a great leap forward from
socialism into communism that would
somehow leave the Soviet Union behind
his hope was to upstage Nikita who
Schaaf and become the leader of the
socialist camp
hundreds of millions of ordinary people
in the countryside were herded into
giant collectives called people's
communes these people's communes
were modeled on the army with collective
contains collective dormitories by
transforming every man and every woman
in the countryside into a foot soldier
and a giant army to be deployed day and
night to transform the economy mal
thought that he could catapult his
country past the Soviet Union but the
Great Leap Forward was a disaster it led
to literally tens of millions of people
being starved beaten worked to death
villagers had no incentive to work the
land was no longer theirs their tools
utensils even pots and pans had all been
confiscated they were literally wondered
servants of the state at the back and
call of local Carter's they earned work
points to be exchanged for food in
canteens but the Carters on the other
hand had to whip up the workforce in one
relentless drive after the other
produced more fertilizer more grain more
steel from backyard furnaces that to
whip up the workforce so the scope and
degree of coercion had to be constantly
expanded resulting in a mounting spiral
of violence in order to get impoverished
famished people to work
they were pummeled beaten whipped some
of them tied up thrown into ponds
covered in excrement branded with
sizzling tools occasionally buried alive
but the most important tool at the
disposal of party Carter's to punish
people who didn't work hard enough was
food food was used as a weapon in many
parts of the country
those were too weak or too old to work
were deliberately banned from the
canteens and allowed to starve to death
what I'm trying to say is that people
didn't simply starve to death
they were starved to death the Great
Leap Forward came to an end in 1962 at
great cost and it damaged the standing
of maltitol
he wondered whether somebody might
destroy his legacy as it happened with
Stalin would the beef a Chinese who shoe
off to denounce him even if even as he
was still alive
and most of all how would Chairman Mao
be able to spot the Chinese who shop
since Stalin himself had been unable to
identify his own nemesis and had even
promoted who shaft through the ranks of
the party Mao's response was the
Cultural Revolution he prepared it very
carefully
it began in 1966 four years later
the Cultural Revolution was designed to
be an attacking feudal bourgeois
capitalist culture that now believed was
a threat to communist ideology but now
also used the Cultural Revolution to
unleash ordinary people and punish all
those inside the party hierarchy who had
ever expressed any doubt about him and
the Great Leap Forward first students in
the summer of 1966 were allowed to
criticize their teachers they rapidly
became Red Guards and also attacked what
they refer to as the old world burning
books vandalizing churches tearing down
temples attacking any sign of the past
in Shanghai alone they raided a quarter
of a million homes taking away ordinary
books family photographs but also
antique bronzes rare paintings all of it
destroyed they also attacked people they
suspected were enemies of the revolution
in Beijing alone in September 1966 a
thousand seven hundred of them were
killed a few thousand petrol and
satellite a number also electrocuted in
the autumn of 1966 Mao went further and
allowed ordinary people to criticize
ranking party members which they did but
people of course became divided over who
the true enemies of the Cultural
Revolution were so they started fighting
each other and the army intervened as
Mao asked them to support
true proletarian laughed but different
offices in the Army weren't quite sure
either who they should fight and ended
up fighting each other in the streets
the country was on the very edge of
civil war this episode comes to an end
of 1968 a so-called new revolutionary
party committees appear they represent a
command structure that Mao relished top
to bottom one man in every place the
military structure and these so-called
revolutionary party committees were
heavily dominated by the army with
soldiers overseeing factories schools
offices they turn China into a garrison
State their first act was to punish all
the students and red guards who had
taken the Chairman at his word
sending literally millions of them to
the countryside to be re-educated by the
peasants other purges followed in
Shanghai anyone with a foreign link in
the past was seen to be suspect 170,000
people who were harassed thousands
killed or committing suicide in
Guangdong province alone the province
just across the border from Hong Kong
where I work and live one estimate puts
the body count at 40,000 but of course
mouth was suspicious of everyone and
also the army that now run the country
in September 1971 Lin Bo
the very man would besieged Chun Kuen in
Manchuria and 1948 conveniently died in
a plane accident now the army was purged
in turn at this point in 1971 ordinary
people in the countryside realize that
the
Cultural Revolution has badly damaged
the Communist Party of China the
credibility of communism was destroyed
by the Great Leap Forward and the famine
but the organization of the party was
undermined by the Cultural Revolution
ordinary people villages stopped what I
refer to as a silent revolution even
before mail dies they take back the land
they take back their tools they open
black markets they operate underground
factories they return to the past and as
not a lot the party can do about it no
party would have tolerated open
confrontation but these are millions and
millions of daily acts of resistance as
people wrench away from the state very
basic economic freedoms Mao dies in 1976
three years later a man referred to as
Deng Xiaoping take his place short last
a little man he had purged intellectuals
in 1957 and he would do the same again
and again and again but done shopping at
first attempted to force villagers to go
back to the people's communes he soon
realized that he doesn't have didn't
have the clout to do it
so he's wise enough to step back and
allow ordinary people to just get on
with their economic business the
people's communes collapsed in 1982 from
here onwards very basic economic
freedoms produce economic growth that
economic growth is used by the party to
rebuild itself
things are pengon as followers are
determined to allow some economic
leniency but equally determined to
suppress every political aspiration so
many twists and turns in this story not
least the massacre around Tienanmen
square in june 1989 but overall human
ingenuity managed to thrive despite the
constraints of the one-party state if
you have acclaimed what has happened
since 1979
as nothing short of an economic miracle
well if you look at the gross domestic
product per capita according to the
International Monetary Fund China ranked
number 126 in 1980 by the time the tanks
move into tenement square has moved up
to 121 where it remains until the end of
the 20th century only to increase by
five ranks up to 2007 at that point is
just below Zimbabwe and the Mugabe he's
gone thank God for that and just just
below Zimbabwe just above Turkmenistan
that's what China is in 2007 it is true
that after the crisis in 2008 it jumps
all the way up from 116 jumps all the
way up to 76 quite an achievement in
fact for anyone who has visited China 10
15 20 years ago it seems as if it is a
different country and indeed one of the
accomplishments of the regime today is
to have distanced itself so successful
from the Maui rrah that it doesn't even
appear to exist the no monuments to the
victims of the Cultural Revolution no
memorials for the tens of millions who
died during Mao's Great Famine but on
the other hand skyscrapers everywhere
bullet trains modern airports modern
railways roses along the highways it's
almost like a paradise isn't it
but when you scratch that shimmering
surface what you will discover
underneath are the iron under pendings
of the one-party state the very
institutions put in place by Mao after
1949 have been spruced up there is for
instance the propaganda department which
hasn't changed its function since Mao
although today conveniently it is
translated officially into English as
the publicity Department then there is
the Ministry of security and the
Ministry of State Security two giants
that reach out into every single
household does the Bureau of Statistics
that produced the numbers required to
portray the Great Leap Forward as a
miracle and the Bureau of Statistics
continues to produce the figures that
the party the mounts and then of course
there is the organization department
that anyone familiar with commerce
regimes will immediately identify as the
one that is responsible for appointing
leading party members to shadow every
government institution if Hillsdale were
to be taken over by the Communist Party
of China tomorrow it's god forbid
it would mean that the mayor of
Hillsdale is appointed by the
organization Department the president
Hillsdale College is appointed by the
organization Department the organization
Department will appoint a party
secretary to every department and decide
who teaches what what should be
researched and who should be invited my
feeling is I would not be welcome after
1949 Mao destroyed all organizations
outside of the organization of the
Communist Party of China
he placed a party in a position to rob
the people of their assets that
situation has not fundamentally changed
the land belongs to the states the banks
belonged to the states the industry
belongs to the state major enterprises
are controlled directly or indirectly by
the state economists have observed that
consumption levels tend to be low and
the People's Republic of China they are
low because their wealth goes to the
state and from the state to the party
not to ordinary people
well you might object and say it's not
communist they allow private property
really but every single leader from
maltitol onwards including shipping as
made it crystal clear that there will
not be separation of powers and there is
none there is no judicial independence
which means that there is no rule of law
which means that you cannot defend your
private property if you read the
Constitution you will find out that what
is referred to as socialist property
is apparently sacred but not so private
property you might say but there plenty
of billionaires in China yes they
occasionally disappear for a while they
are they reappear on TV to confess or
you never see them again
their assets now belong to the state and
other billionaires than scurry to prove
the loyalty to the party in essence
despite all the talk about reform and
opening-up over the last 40 years the
Communist Party has remained in charge
of the economy the commanding heights of
the economy are controlled by the party
you may very well argue that there are
relative merits to a one-party state
for instance stability or at least the
appearance of stability during economic
crises for instance the one in 2008 but
to think that the Chinese Communist
Party will undertake meaningful economic
or political reform I think is mistaken
its hand is everywhere and will not move
of its own accord to think otherwise to
believe that political reform will
follow economic reform as every American
president has done from Nixon onwards
except for the one in Washington today
is to engage in what I call a China
fantasy thank you
[Applause]
Thank You dr. de Carter has agreed to
sign copies of his book Mao's Great
Famine directly following this session
in the sural Lobby outside and we now
have time for a few questions so please
make your way to the microphone if you
have a question and I am reminded by our
director that students who ask good
questions will be considered for extra
credit okay you say that I learned that
you're a professor at the university of
hong kong how does it like teaching
there with the situation that's going on
right there right now it's a good
question but I haven't taught that the
last three months in fact I haven't even
been in Hong Kong I was at the Hoover
Institution in July in August
I've been in Europe since I was only in
Hong Kong for one day I was happy the
airport was open having said that I have
nothing but admiration for the people of
Hong Kong and I have to say I have
slightly less admiration for the police
I understand that occasionally you might
wish to use tear gas and fire rubber
bullets and club people on the head but
you must have a strategy that the only
result is that those demonstrators move
from one street to another it seems
rather pointless it fuels anger it
creates more protesters more grievances
well it's crystal clear is that many of
these very young people some of them
probably my own students are utterly
determined because they've seen whatever
few freedoms they have being very gladly
undermined by the one-party state across
the border in 1997 Hong Kong was
returned from Britain was a crown colony
to the People's Republic of China
People's Republic of China undertook to
not change its institutions for 50 years
and promised free elections that promise
has been broken now
those few freedoms of being crushed
people are upset and rightly saw I have
nothing but admiration for them all
right next question thank you for your
talk
from my limited knowledge of Chinese
history it seems that the regime has had
various weaknesses that you've pointed
to but with the recent implementation of
their Social Credit System and the
massive surveillance state that they've
built it seems that they have would be
able to correct a lot of these
weaknesses and I wonder if you might be
able to speak to that it's important not
to overestimate your enemy it's
important not to underestimate him
either we tend to think of dictatorships
the societies which are beautifully
regimented from top to bottom the truth
is under the Nazis under Stalin under
Mao it is chaos why because there's
never just one dictator there are a
million of them I'll be my little
dictator here there are thousand rules
and thousands of regulations they're
implemented according to the whim of the
person who happens to be in charge
it creates chaos on the ground there's
true to this day I go to China this year
before July I went virtually every
second week our cameras everywhere in
Shanghai people we are told will be
fined if they jaywalk I do it
everybody does it happily
except if there's a policeman standing
right there to stop you but as he stops
you somebody else will cross
Aniki when I travel I'm always a little
apprehensive because these people at
airports railway stations
customs is across the border from Hong
Kong into china are obviously unable to
read a passport they don't know who I am
how do you spell my name it's all a
great mystery so before we get to this
Orwellian state where everybody's
registered and regimented I think China
will have a very long way to go with one
exception and that is of course the
outer realms of the Empire the
Bolsheviks inherited that Tsarist Empire
Mao inherited the Ching Empire the
boundaries are the same they haven't
decolonized yet so when it comes to
Tibet and since young there are
definitely cameras everywhere and every
means possible is used to punish people
there are more cameras probably in some
villages in Tibet than there are tax
ports for children so tremendously poor
villages yet you will see cameras on
every street so in that sense yes it's
definitely a threat hello I have a quick
question regarding the sinking in the
Inner Mongolia and the Tibet
sitting at Sun I believe he said that
one of the reasons you can implement
democracy into China immediately was
because people weren't ready for sort of
the country wasn't unified yet so
somebody had to unify the government
first and then allow for freedom and
elections is this what the People's
Republic of China is doing with their
sign Association of the
Sinkiang inner mongolia and tibet in
order to prevent separatist movements
once they democratize so there's two
questions one a sin yet son one is what
happened after 1949 very clearly this is
an empire that pretends to be a nation
state so what you see is the same
timezone whether you travel to see
Chiang also Manchuria regions that are
extremely far away from each other
there's the imposition of Mandarin one
standard language at the detriment of
local languages everything is to do with
with unification with the imposition of
one particular standard one culture one
timezone etc etc but I wish to say
something about Sun yat-sen he may very
well have said that but the truth is
that after the Empire collapsed in 1911
China was the very first Republic in
Asia some 40 million people voted in
1912 or 10% of the population it was a
an electoral representation that was not
reached by Japan until 1928 I think
India till 1935 there was a huge
interest from 1912 until 1949 in
participatory democracy there were civil
associations there was an attempt to
separate out powers and build up an
independent judicial system all too
often we skipped the entire first half
of the 20th century as if Mao somehow
came from nowhere but the truth is that
the Republic of China the period from
1912 to 1949 demonstrates that China can
perfectly well be a democratic open
thriving society and that's what we have
to bear in mind
all right so uh thank you for coming to
yell so I appreciate you coming
so trying to being per Mac pragmatic
here in September of 2019 you mentioned
right the end of your talk about not
engaging in a China fantasy with the
current administration so I want to hear
your thoughts on what we're doing right
what we're doing wrong how our current
dispute with China is likely to in
specifically with the tariffs and the
trade war so I want to see what you
thought what your thoughts are on that
well I don't know how it will end
I'm a historian I study the past not the
future but you want my guess well as I
pointed out at the very end of my talk
for the first time you have a president
who seems to know how to unsettle that
regime profoundly
and you have somebody who appears to
understand that the biggest threat to
your freedom and mine as well comes from
the People's Republic of China with the
largest organization on planet Earth
devoted to crushing the very values of
freedom and democracy how does the trade
war war the right way of doing this well
my understanding of Adam Smith and free
trade is that we live in an island no
you good at fishing yeah five fish I
have five coconuts every day we exchange
you're wealthier I'm wealthier but as I
pointed out when Europeans buy stuff
from China when Americans buy stuff from
China the theory would be that Chinese
people will buy stuff from Europe and
stuff from the United States but they
don't it's called financial repression
the wealth flows to the party their bank
accounts belong to the state the state
does as it sees fit
with the money of other people it will
build these empty airports it will build
these empty railways it will build up
that mighty army it has so in that sense
it's not free trade and it most
certainly isn't fair trade so again the
trade war seems to me to be a reasonable
approach all the more if you studied the
economy of China since 1979 and you
realize how extraordinarily dependent
they are on earning foreign currency in
the beginning I said everything goes
back to Stalin we may think of the
economy today as being utterly different
but what did Stalin do with the first
famine first communist famine 29 32 33
he took massive stocks of food from the
countryside to sell it on the
international market in order to buy the
industrial equipment needed
to modernize the Soviet Union he wanted
foreign currency that's exactly what mal
did that's exactly what dung did that's
exactly what she does the only
difference on the dung on the mal trade
would be with the socialist bloc under
dung its with the rest of the world but
this is a machine devoted to making sure
that china can sell as much as possible
at a very small margin there are tax
rebates there are subsidies the massive
huge state structures behind it and all
of that foreign currency is needed to
keep the rest of the country afloat so
if you poke a hole in that then you see
the leaders in Beijing scurry because
they are so incredibly dependent on you
and your US dollars like you will weaken
them very quickly Thank You Anne for
coming out tonight um I have a question
pertaining to the issue of Hong Kong and
ultimately the ideology of China
it seems one consistent theme throughout
let me just hold it okay gotcha yeah it
seems like one consistent theme is the
method doesn't matter the only thing
that matters is the result which is more
power or the control over the people
whether it be modernization or literally
tearing down a culture how then can the
United States defend cities like Hong
Kong or an entire quasi country like
Taiwan when the government literally
does not care what what the means but
securing what they want is there any
actual strategy we can draw up or is it
just simply like playing checkers back
and forth well as I said don't over
don't overestimate your enemy don't
underestimate him we may think that Hong
Kong is just a small city of eight
million people with its laws with its
independent judicial system and across
the border is 1.4 billion people they
call it one country two systems' really
seems a little unbalanced doesn't it
hardly fair
for 8 million people to put up a fight
to preserve not require new freedoms
provoke preserve the ones they have what
can you do if that 1.4 million machine
is determined to crush Hong Kong well
guess what goes back to what I said
earlier on the wealth goes to the party
and party members do you think they have
any faith in their own system no these
billionaires who I mentioned
occasionally disappear and their wealth
from one day to the next become state
property if you smart your money you
place it in Hong Kong there are
thousands of companies in Hong Kong from
the mainland some 60% of inward
investment comes from Hong Kong 60% of
outward investment goes through Hong
Kong is vital that tried to replicate it
with Shenzhen and Shanghai and they've
failed because they don't have
separation of powers so sometimes it
just seems but you're fighting a monster
that you can't beat but remember the
Soviet Union was the same story in the
1970s people would come back from
Siberia and say oh these Soviets they're
going to overtake the world well they've
got a system we can't beat you know they
crush democracy but the result is a
strong man they can do things we simply
can't get away with it's the last fight
how could you possibly fight them well
it disintegrated more or less with a bit
of help from another chap who's out
there
Ronald he's a bit fenced off though
so there are many tools that you can use
to fight the one-party state and many of
these tools actually come straight in
Europe in this country from our
experience of the Cold War and one
approach of the Cold War is to have one
standard for everyone not a double
standard and this is the issue so much
knowledge about the Soviet Union and the
moment we talk about China is as if all
that knowledge just evaporates why
because when we used to talk about the
Soviet Union it was about politics not
about culture nobody in his right mind
would stand up and say the Soviet Union
is a different culture you know that's
the Orthodox Church no the Orthodox
Church was crushed survived now we talk
about China it's the exact opposite it's
not about politics it's about culture
read Henry Kissinger I'm not really
communist it's Confucian culture these
people are wonderful are not true
communist three presidents said this
Roosevelt he thought all these are just
agrarian reformers so let's not help
chung-kai shake him mount satsang is a
good chap well a few years later they
were finding them in Korea didn't go all
that well next then Kissinger same story
oh it's Confucian culture they're not
like the Soviet Union we should use them
against the Soviet Union you know allow
them access under Clinton under Reagan
I'm sorry to say allow them access to
our technology seldom weapons have the
students do things we would never do
with the Soviet Union still at collapse
on 89 90 91 then Clinton 94 after the
Tiananmen Massacre same story help them
with their economy and they will reform
surely as the carp follows the Ox didn't
happen either one standard you sign a
treaty you respect the treaty you say
you will do something you stick to you
would one standard for treatment of
human beings thank you you keep a few
more pressing I'm happy to go on as long
as you want that's all I'm concerned
it's two o'clock in the morning so I
hope it doesn't take that long I'm not
very good at this
about 25 some years ago I established a
hundred percent foreign owned company in
China and about a year ago I sold it and
I asked engaged at my wife's help who's
Chinese I engaged a local a very
high-level accountant to advise me on
how to deal with these with the cash
[Music]
several million millions of dollars and
I said well maybe you know buy a new car
some things oh no you better not do that
we have to be very careful with this if
this is not spent just exactly you can
go to jail go to jail this question I've
been getting the question I'm sorry so
said well my children have a hundred
thousand dollar tuition coming up can we
spend on that oh sure no problem
[Music]
am I is China ever gonna let me allow me
to spend that money how I would like to
without having to it a jail I mean it's
I will give you my voice don't things
don't happen dollar fee I don't think
you go to jail but all these
billionaires in China are a lot smarter
than you are because they grew up in
this system and they are desperate to
get the money out of the country so
chances of you succeed in a pretty slim
I'm sorry to say all right we have time
for one more question no capital
capitalism free movement of goods people
not in China hey I want to thank you
again for coming out here tonight so
you've spoken a lot about the ways in
which Mao took things from Stalin's
ideology and Stalin's implementation of
policies however I know that those who
are sympathetic to to Mao or to the
Chinese system would be quick to point
out differences between what Mao and
Stalin did and would point out that they
often disagreed on on certain things I
was wondering if maybe you could speak a
little bit towards to what extent some
of those differences might be
substantial and to what extent they are
superficial you want another lecture I'm
happy to give you one I said I talked
briefly about how Mao destroyed every
organization outside of the organization
of the Communist Party of China what do
you think out of Hitler did after 1933
here's your German word of the day
glacial tone a process of
synchronization in which the Nazis over
the course of two three years take over
every single institution down to your
local sports club now all cultures
eliminate it and replace with Nazi
paraphernalia where did where did he get
it from he got from Lannon when there
was the first one to do it
ultimately of course these are different
the mouth 1949 is not the mouth 1956 the
differences between mounds Stalin are
plentiful you can find all sorts of
differences but to emphasize difference
is to not see the overall picture and
the overall picture I think is
reasonably straightforward in the 20th
century you have two trends that are
opposed one is to separate out powers
goes back to that French chap
Montesquieu don't you do philosophy
that's what I thought and sociology
tough
Montesquieu first came up with the idea
of separation of powers other
philosophers did so true for centuries
in parts of Europe the United States
other parts of the world people have
been working very hard at coming up with
Jack's and balances an independent
judicial system complicated arrangements
but sometimes you have to hire a lawyer
make an Boris Johnson do this or that
you need lawyers difficult not sure he
might end up in jail it's a great
achievement can extraordinary for any
government seen from the Stone Age
onwards a human beings club each other
for all of a sudden the government to
respect a court order is an
extraordinary achievement
that's one train the other trend is the
concentration of power with Lenin with
Hitler Mussolini
you name it these dictators think that
all that wishy-washy separation of
powers only weakens the entire entity
what you ought to do is concentrate
powers in the hands of one party
represented by one person so yes I could
go on about differences between Stalin
and Mao but ultimately it's the same
mechanism it's the same vision it's the
same desire to control power and keep it
firmly in the hands of the party state
I'd say one difference is that Stalin at
the height of the terror in the 1930s at
least had the courage to sign all the
death warrants there are about 1.5
million of them he had to sign his long
books with list of names he signed it
now pitted people against each other he
made sure everybody had blood on their
hands but it's a minor detail ultimately
it's the one-party state that is barely
different from the beginning of the
century to the very end
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]